hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen wieder bei dem
verschollenen projektgebiete natürlich
nicht verschollen es waren ein paar tage
ausgesetzt wegen karneval wegen paar
anderen dingen die wir vor gefallen sind
ist es prima zusammen mit um gespielt
hier sind wir wieder wert paar server
server schwierigkeiten und viele leute
haben uns server angeboten allerdings
haben es jetzt selber hinbekommen und es
sollte jetzt bei simon gut klappen und
bei mir auch wir haben interesse mit den
portugiesen zu unseren eigenen italo
server und der liebe morys vom team
spielen eingerichtet
vielen dank aber hier aber er hat auch
ein bus gebaut wir haben doch gerade weg
gemacht ja der hat da irgendwie ein
bisschen gebraucht und ich habe mich
gewundert was sind das für bus dann habe
ich den bus kommt erstmal weg gemacht
gut was wir machen wollten war danke
erst mal alle dies irgendwie kommentare
geschrieben und das wollten auch noch
mal sagen und zwar wenn er leute die da
schreiben bei mir zum beispiel hey seid
voll dumm ihr lest ihr in die kommentare
sagte über ihr lest die blabla ja
natürlich wir nehmen immer so acht
folgen am stück auf oder so heute wird
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders sein
an dem wir nicht so viel auf und können
dementsprechend dann erst acht folgen
später auf eure genannten tipps eingehen
wie zum beispiel das mit dem rapper das
wiedereintritt töpfe brauchen und das
ist auch das was ich erstmal heute
machen werde und zwar mehr speed up
basteln und damit dann diese räume holen
damit wir daraus die chinesen machen
können und damit wir uns da raus da in
seinen mails raider hieß es glaub ich
machen kann ergibt also kann es durch
oder aber genau und du kümmerst dich
weiter um das haus damit das haus fertig
wird nein
guckt man bitte nach dass wir dass du
dieses maze runner oder generator oder
freundes oder irgendwie sowas hinkriegt
ich habe dir mal diesen link gesendet
von dieser nachricht
übrigens haben wir wieder ein paar
nachrichten bekommen die habe ich jetzt
einfach mal gesendet
bei skype ab ich habe einfach nicht ich
habe ja schon öffnet wie sehe ich da
rechts an leitet dieses noch nachts auf
items wo ich die ganze aussehen welche
knöpfe zu drücken
zudem drücke
passiert nichts wie nehmen was meinst du
ich finde die nachricht aber danke auf
jeden fall dass wir uns alle des links
ich habe einfach vornehmen acht deswegen
ist eine art noch im gamersgate extrakte
aus dem carport okay aber ich wollte
macht des bildes alte ich alles okay
wenn man dem game mode ist sieht man
sich diese diese items hier denken wir
würden nicht nur so wenn man hier auf
klickt dann sieht man nur wie die sachen
gemacht werden also stellt euer leben
weil wir wollen sich bei spiel spaß
verderben sache so freunde und hier
sehen wir jetzt ein dings die türen
dingsbums sei man jetzt einmal mächtig
drauf dann kriege ich das dann habe ich
hier 13 7 30 217 und dann kriege ich da
auch immer welche raus also immer stieg
bis ins detail heißt ich muss da gar
nichts wollen worten die konnte ich mir
einfach direkt holen
maze mails raid 1 raid ich habe dir doch
mal so ein bild von den nach abgesendet
da stand das irgendwie drin was wir
brauchen mail servers generate auf jeden
fall generator was geht das auch kein
mensch braucht es auch was hast du schon
gebaut
ich habe noch nichts gebaut ich habe nur
ein paar einzelteile gesammelt also der
mann ja auch dass es lange dauert bis
wir damit fertig sein werden
in geht also nur electric circus okay ja
genau dafür braucht er lava und kopper
kupfer habe ich auf jeden fall ein tool
redstone und iron okay das ist ein
raffiniert teil also raffiniertes einen
also einfach besuchs einfach in diesem
ding könnte auch einfach klick ich weiß
nicht was einfach solche augenblicke
das ist anderes eine ganz normale
eisenbach zusammen mit einer kohle und
einem minimum stein werden zusehen mini
umständlich junge oder stein der weisen
gibts hier hast du übrigens danke an die
leute die meinten dass ich mit meiner
termine spitzhacke auch dings abbauen
kann oxidieren das wussten wir nämlich
gar nicht und zwar werden wir deswegen
jetzt auch in dieser folge mal ein
bisschen ob sie ihren abbauen würde ich
sagen für wofür braucht wer das sieht ja
nochmal für den vertrieb sich zum
beispiel und so was ja stimmt für die
tombola schneisen barren eisenbach muss
einfach nur noch mal ein schmelzen
dann werden noch mal also das probier s
mal aus eisen sache noch mal beim
wettbewerb bei mir ruckelt noch manchmal
aber da musst du deine grafik
einstellung auf max fps zu erstellen das
gemacht
oh ich bin noch ganz viel glas hab ich
warte ich mal die rendite ist einfach
auf normal +0 96 bald kommt ja endlich
mein neuer pc an in ziemlich genau
sieben tagen oder 99 tagen kommt er an
wenn ihr diese folge seht in acht tagen
und ja das hier zu halten sie für meinen
pc kommt 12 monaten
weil ich warten auf die neue nvidia
grafikkarten komplett neuen pc zusammen
aber am freitag schon also seid mal wir
haben das schon rief ein teil davon habe
ich schon richtig viel gemacht
eigentlich ja aber wir haben das doch
schon wieso machst nur noch mehr weil
was alles kann man damit anfangen
wir brauchen einmal mehr von warum warum
das fest der liebe konnte
das macht es einfach einfach weil wir es
können
weil seine woche noch ganz oft von
diesem kabel und sowas und die ganzen
sachen und übrigens könnt ihr uns ja
aber auch mal in die kommentare
schreiben wir werden dann in ein paar
folgen anwenden also schild hier mit den
bienen werte brauchen wir denn da genau
sind ihr die drohne idee eine prinzessin
tapfere drohne tapfere königin was dort
alles dazu bedeuteten habt könnt ihr uns
auch in die kommentare schreiben
das wäre sehr nett von euch und nicht
alle gleich ausrasten wenn wir dann so
was für ein mensch verbraucht mit
pflastersteine flint electronics circuit
wie macht man den dafür brauchen wir
kompakt kabel kupferkabel macht man mit
rhabarberkompott körper körper also
brauchen auf jeden fall kupfer okay
kupfer habe ich in patron ziemlich viel
also ich glaub wir haben 30 oder 40
kupfer gut dann kümmere ich mich um die
copaco ich mache ich mache trotzdem
erstmal unser haus zu weihnachten dunkel
wird und es stimmt explodiert dann
stehen wenn ich damit den unseren tun
niemand von der letzte risiko aber noch
mal brennen im ofen gibt einfach einfach
mal schnell einfach anrufen bringen
schließlich könnte es einfach mal
probieren probieren
also ich mache erst mal schöne fenster
war dein vater vor stehe ich hab den
damals nicht verstanden habe ich
einverstanden aber immer noch nicht
witzig ich bin ja auch richtig und
lustig aber die kiwis 7 jackpot apropos
steckborn florian weiss ich mache ich
mach hier sind richtig krasse rabba
osterholz fan in den rockhimmel rabatt
andere brauchen bald gar nicht das ganze
theoretisch gleich wieder abbrechen ich
habe gleich mal ordentlich eine schöne
runde und dann mache ich ein richtig
schöner brauch holz haben sowie 2 1 und
alles jederzeit überall zu holz wie viel
holz hilft da fehlt da unten aus dem
außenamt falken am balken außen aber
dass nicht das holz ich muss auch noch
mal in der mine und dienst abbauen ob
ceo hier kommt dann raus da ist das holz
ist in welcher tour aber ich habe jetzt
sechs wörter haben wir kupfer haben wir
ziemlich viel erwarte er da sind wir 16
kupfer machen und noch mal sieben koffer
enkels warum heißt es eine kopf erinnert
ist eine koffer packen weil das eine
vielleicht nicht die blöcke sind es gibt
immer alle verfahren und sah
zu zwei verschiedene items hey das
gleiche opfer brachen koppelt das ist
eigentlich das gleiche vielleicht noch
nicht übersetzt oder so ich weiß nicht
das problem sein halb deutschland wollen
ein komplett deutsches spiel das
deutsche spiel
wenn jemand jetzt nicht falsch
aufgekommen
als das deutsche spiel nachlaufen
ich hab' ich habe sechs kupferkabel und
für einen major brauchen wir für eine
electronics 2,6 körper cable redstone
dieses unser großes fenster haus ist
schon mal gar nicht so hässlich ganz so
hessen gar nicht ist so ist es war
hässlich aber nicht so es wäre
wunderschön das jetzt erstmal so unser
handelszentrum unser handelsblatt später
reinkommt
wir haben noch nie machen dass die bäume
die riesige gebäude alles muss kann man
ganz gut zu überlegen da mache ich drei
koffer cable wird so cool
es wird so cool so gut wir haben die
abens haus verschlossen vor bösen
menschen vermissen tieren und alles sehr
gut
ja ich habe eine elektronik sorgt für
den mails rater das heißt wir brauchen
jetzt auf alle drei flint haben wir das
schon sehr bestimmt guck mal hier guck
mal hier noch an top es ist ein
electronics show wird geil damit
anfangen weiß nicht aber wir brauchen
auf jeden fall
wir brauchen eine maschine eigentlich
auch wenn ich ganz rezepte sich blickt
er trotzdem schon optisch durch ich auch
nicht aber ich weiß wie so etwas geht
also mega kompliziert apropos e-mails
retter hätten wir dann eigentlich schon
fertig wir brauchen jetzt nur noch dann
gewährt hatte zwei pflastersteine und
drei flint ich weiß nicht wie viel flint
hast du blind euro das sind 3 ok ich
hab' gleich machen setzen dings sind
nachgemessen
ich mache es jetzt ein neues rating
wir haben mehr trader die erste
challenge ist fertig von den drei wochen
geboren guck mal was in handhabt behörde
damit machen wir müssen das in der mitte
stellen und links daneben generate oder
so und dann können wir das alles so
dundee als verdreifachen oder so ich
glaube wenn die nacht zuvor bei ist dann
schneide ich das dann passt das ist
schon die erste